how long have you guys known each other
he was the first person i met when i
moved to l.a so over
two years ago over two years ago i've
known kane
oh wow cool that's awesome and
when you when you first met like what
was the first thing because you know
when you
doesn't matter who you meet if you're
going to be friends with someone you got
to connect on some level there's got to
be something in common what was it that
you guys were like oh yeah
we're tight now well i'll tell you what
it wasn't his red shoes
red ruby shoes that i first saw him in
but i would say more
um i was exploring buddhism a little bit
more and i didn't really have a guide or
somebody to talk to about that and
kane was so into buddhism i was like
dude we we got it we gotta hang it only
because of buddhism i became your friend
because
on the surface level i would not talk to
people like you i mean
other people like there's so many people
like him in l.a with like you know the
perfect body but like when you like that
like hello is there anyone
in here like no but kevin's really smart
it doesn't show it no yeah i don't want
to show because then people will think
i'm like you know
smart
it's it becomes too much of an advantage
yeah
it's too much of an advantage for you
maybe yeah i like
yeah the new paris sultan
[Music]
mccain he finishes my sentences now
i love that so given that you guys have
you know you formed this relationship
years ago how did you end up becoming
involved in this show
together kelly
kelly introduced me kylie was one of the
first people i met
before i moved to la she saw a video i
was doing on uh
huffington post actually specifically
and she said dude your message is great
if you're
ever in la let's let's hang out let's
meet up and then i moved to la
because i was moving out of philadelphia
and i just said to her i was like i need
new friends here and she's like hey
whatever you need like i got this one
guy
i think you guys are really quick and
then that's when i met kane and then we
just started hanging out a lot and then
they told me about a project and i was
like okay cool
and that's it and that's where we are
today right
yep yeah i've known a lot of the cast
members as well like kelly i'm known as
a friend for like eight years
christine you know social circles and
stuff the only person i didn't really
know was
uh kevin and then anna and we became
like amazing friends from the show so
yeah it's interesting with
shows like yours like i'm always curious
about you know before you guys start
what your expectations are and then when
you're in it
it if you feel like you're being
represented the way that you actually
are i mean the the thing is that you
know all of us i mean i'm not kevin but
come from very successful backgrounds
and you know families
we were very i was like really
apprehensive going on a show like that
similar to anna
and you know meeting with jeff i just
you know the first few meetings i'm like
i'm gonna call you uncle jeff because
i felt like he was so trustworthy and
you know um he was very protective about
us as well
so before shooting the show he's like
what you guys don't want to talk about
what you guys
want to like for example for me it was
my family i keep it very private
and i i you know and till today until
now to the show i don't think i
mentioned my family
so i'm very um happy with that yeah
yeah for me i wasn't worried about the
way i'd be represented because they told
me just be yourself
and that the producers actually said
this is the first time you don't have to
talk about
what it's like being asian growing up
like the emasculation or the
the prejudice the racism it's like you
get a chance to
represent an asian guy and not
just the rich asian guy but the everyday
asian guy that could be like an everyday
asian guy sorry i'm not saying i'm
an everyday asian guy but an asian guy
that a normal person can look up to
and i was like i would jump on that
opportunity to heartbeat
um because you know like i'm just so
used to especially seeing
in scripted shows like just a portrayal
that i wasn't very comfortable
with and when i told them i don't want
to be a part of that
those betrayals they said it's great we
don't want that either you can be you
and in a reality space where asian men
aren't even seen as like sexual
or like cool you know what i mean like
i've never seen an asian guy on like the
bachelor
on whatever you know like just yeah i
wasn't doing stuff
yeah i'm i'm kind of half surprised you
have a shirt on
yeah i know because like in the show
it's like you're not you're
50 you're not wearing clothes he's gonna
take it off for you carlos just wait
till here
just for you he's gonna do it today
well they're marketing this is like you
know it's like the reality show version
of crazy rich asians and kevin to your
point
you know when that movie came out one of
the big things about it was like
we're going to take off that sort of
wall of having to explain ourselves
and then everyone just gets to see us as
who we are with our traditions and what
our relationships
are like uh cain for you
i don't know if you've seen the movie at
all but i'm wondering if like
if you did does that represent you did
you see that and go yep that's what my
life was like okay kevin's taking his
clothes
i had a lot of like press reach out for
me after that movie and like you know
and
i think there was a yahoo article that
they're like you know these are the five
kids that you know as represented you
know that we took this
um uh just based the movie on and i feel
like
you know there are quite similar
representations in terms of that you
know whole like
um you know and on the show i showed
that struggle with my dad you know being
from the asian family being like the
eldest son
you know and i'm also the only
singaporean on the show
so you know being la you know like as an
asian parent you always want your eldest
kid to take over the business
so you know this um yeah
what kind of pressures do you guys think
that you uh
that you face i mean living living in
los angeles and now
in a way like opening yourself up to the
scrutiny of the public
i think kevin's inviting that see the
shirts coming out already
dude it's hot here in l.a like
right it's coming out
but literally carlos like the pressures
that i face is because
most people in la know me as like the
guy who talks about representation
and like asian guy and just the
the feelings of uh feeling less than
right then western guys or whatever or
be even treated like that
so i feel like i face the pressure of
like well why would you join a group
like this where
it's just increasing the stereotype of
wealth and
all of that stuff and we don't want to
be represented like this but then i
always say it's like well
the way we were represented before
really wasn't working either
and my thing is i also don't want to be
boxed
into one category even from asian people
like we have to be polished we can't say
stuff like that we can't show our flaws
we need to be
a certain type and very respectful
and humble and all that kind of stuff
and i'm like we have that but we also
have humanistic forms of other things
too
for me the pressure would be like you
know i'm i'm from another country and
like people just assume i have money and
i'm stupid
and so i get a lot of these people that
you know just like hey would you like to
invest in this
and like the thing is they look at me
thinking i'm just like like a bank and
somebody i'm not stupid
you know i've done i've built my own
business since i'm 17
i'm helping kevin with a supplement line
we're working on
so you know i think kevin back to your
question on being like you know i'm
mixing with people that come from money
you do want to make money everyone wants
to make money so i think it's smart that
you're assimilating with like people
that come from like successful
backgrounds
as well and they're nice people yeah
yeah no
definitely what you know what else do
you want people to
to get from the show i mean like it's a
lot of fun watching you guys
just go do your thing and like kane when
you're just like yeah let's just go shop
like that's a lot of fun to see but what
else do you want people to be able to
get from uh
from your show i think i want people to
understand that
the more money you have the more
problems you have as well and also i
want people to understand that we're all
you know the same in the end like you
know i lost i didn't
share this on my show but i just lost my
brother going up and that taught me
about life
a lot like you know this material things
this is just for fun and on the show as
well the most rewarding thing i think
i got to experience and also share i
think with the world was the passing of
cherie's mom
i think most people only saw that scene
but like when her mom passed away we
were actually at the hospital and like
we
you know we were chatting with her body
there when you know and it was the most
like i told i called my mom i was like
mom this is the most rewarding thing
i've ever done in my life
and i just want people to also learn
about spirituality
more about buddhism and having
compassion especially right now with the
world where kovit
and there's so much racism against like
asian people so i want people to
you know kind of just have more
compassion to each other and just be
more accepting
yeah yeah i for me i want people to see
asians who are just asians in america
like we're not immigrants speaking
different languages trying to assimilate
and make it or
or just doing martial arts to kick
someone's ass just to get into hollywood
or something right like i want to see
people as like
we're asian americans we have a place in
reality television we have personalities
we have drama and we have hardships just
like everybody else
and we're willing to share it now we're
not the people who are just
quiet and meek and just very straight
laced anymore it's like we have
what it takes to be in a reality space
and i think we can do it very classy
even
yeah do are you prepared for
like the fame that comes along with this
like the amount of people that i'm
going to be yeah carlos i think most of
us i the unique thing about this show is
most of us come from like a little fame
to begin with like
you know most of us have quite a big
following already but obviously this is
gonna be on another scale
um i'm used to it i don't i didn't go
into this for fame i just thought it'd
be a good platform to share
like you know my life and also represent
you know singapore and also
to kind of build my business so i'm not
in this for the fame
actually i'm a bit scared of it um but
kevin's like
more girls to marry i guess
[Laughter]
also too i think the fame of getting
your message out there
like for instance i'd like to have
enough fame for like somebody in korea
to be like oh my god i know
like where your birth parents are i knew
them like i grew up with them or
something
and then i can maybe even get
connections that way through that and
close the story for myself right or like
the theme of
people listen to what i have to say when
i
share about my stories of feeling
unattractive growing up as an asian guy
that they don't just see this clean cut
stupid model right like they they see
like i worked hard
i made sacrifices and chances and i
pursued a career
that's untraditional to asians too um
and so
i think i want people to see all of that
and that's kind of like what i use
what i would want my platform for the
fame is just a byproduct
to me of having an important message to
share
yeah you guys have a lot of fun
with each other and like your
relationship on the show i love the way
that you guys banter back and forth
cane you know you you rip into kevin a
lot for his fashion sense
um do you have my shirt off all the time
i just want to know just just a hot take
from both of you guys
of all your friends are on the show who
actually has the best
fashion sense i think chris to me
hands down to me christine does
i think anna is a boss i mean if you
don't if you see twitter she's like
killing it she's like blowing up on
twitter and like i came to know her from
this show and like became such good
friends
uh taste wise she's you know grew up in
this life and like
just impeccable impeccable taste yeah
right on well uh thank you guys so much
for your time really cool talking to you
and
i do think like this is this is one of
those things where people will see
kevin to your point like a new side of
of um
asian culture so thanks a lot guys thank
you carlos thank you
thank you